so this is one of my essential items um
i carry this around
because i found this on a movie set one
day and it's really cool
because whenever you want to like end
the conversation with someone you just
go
you know i'll be like hey let's start
the conversation about how you owe me
money and
action hey what's up everybody i'm
trevor noah comedian and host of the
daily show
and these are my essentials
[Music]
first item my electric toothbrush
i know it doesn't seem like an essential
thing but this is my real toothbrush
this is my road dog
see those scars look at that there's
battle scars that's
traveling that's ohio that one over
there is tucson
and one of there's austin power
oscillating
pulsating i used to brush my teeth with
a normal toothbrush
and then when you discover this it's
like moving from a horse carriage to a
car
that's what life is all about you forget
to brush your brush twice as hard the
next day
that's what i do all day every day my
grandfather used to say to me he said
trev if you don't brush
you brush when you can that's what i've
been doing ever since
brushing as much as i can
there are a few things in my life i
consider more essential
than headphones these are easily my
favorite things ever i think bose has
done the greatest job of creating noise
cancelling headphones
if you fly you know what it's like to
have a baby
crying these no baby
like i even forgot that i had a baby on
the flight i left the baby behind
then they called me later they're like
yo did you leave a baby and i was like
oh snap
and then i came back then i realized it
wasn't my baby and i was like what just
happened here
that's how good these headphones are and
then these
are great little airpod pros they go
straight into your ear
these are great for like short trips you
know like a little 15 15-minute noise
cancellation thing
i see some people wearing them in the
streets in new york and i don't do that
because i don't want to die
you got to hear what's happening in new
york because sometimes like a bicycle is
flying by
sometimes cars jump the curb it doesn't
happen a lot but it's enough for me to
not want to noise cancel
i want to hear my death coming i'm not
going to avoid the death but i just want
to be able to be like
[Music]
this is an essential if you live in a
city where
there is rain california you can skip
this part
i know you guys don't know what rain is
but the rest of the world
as a little kid i loved umbrellas i
loved mary poppins i loved spies that
could shoot umbrella things you know
like they shoot the little
thing out of the tip that thing so i
found one of these this is my
essential it's an umbrella that opens
the other way
it's like magic look at this huh what
what what what what
you see that other way and then when
you're getting into a car you just do
this move you just do this
and then i meet people at my destination
and they're like oh weren't you in the
rain then i'm like no i was
but i had my essentials and that's why
i'm good
and you're not
[Music]
this is just an essential i don't like
traveling with a laptop
it's too cumbersome it's heavy on my
back also don't like
just having like a tablet because then
sometimes websites are just like are you
using a big phone then i'm like no
i'm using like a big device i want to
see the full website but then they don't
want you to see the website
so this is a surface pro x and it's
basically
a tablet if i need it to be one and then
it's a laptop if i need it to be one
and then what's cool is that i have my
little pen that hides on the inside over
here
see that has a little camera which i
don't use
i don't ever understand how people use
the cameras on these things it looks a
bit weird taking photos like
but it's nice to have a device because
it makes you feel like a professional
and then when people see you typing
they're like wow what is that person
doing
you know this whole thing yeah but if
you on this side you would see
all i'm typing is google how fast
can superman fly wow
[Music]
this lip balm is easily like one of the
most essential things in my life
i have one of these everywhere i've
tried like a bunch of things but i like
the bliss deck specifically
just because i feel like it stays on
your lips for long some chapstick feels
like a scam
you know what i mean like some of the
like you put like a lip balm on and then
it feels like it makes your lips dry
so you need more and i find this doesn't
do that they say it's medicated as well
i don't know what that means but i just
like the sound of anything medicated
just a quick tip though it's gonna break
when you drop it that always happens
see that over there but that's i mean
that's life
you know i'd rather have cracked lid
than crap lips simple essential
this is one of the quirkiest essentials
that i own i think it's one of the most
underrated pieces of technology that's
ever been invented
a pair of glasses known as
spectacles and these were made by
snapchat they may not be everybody's
style
but i love them when i travel because
when i'm on vacation
i don't always like to have my phone out
i feel like it takes you out of the
moment
so what's great about these is you can
wear them and you can just like press a
little button
see over there and right now i'm
recording you recording me
like i've used these when i was fishing
for piranhas in in the amazon jungle uh
i've used these
when i was like like hiking through peru
and what's great is
you don't stick your phone in people's
faces because that's what i hate about
like
traveling a lot of the time is people
just you know also makes me feel like a
spy
because deep down inside i'll always be
11 years old
this is what's known as project xcloud i
have been playing video games
since the very beginning since i knew
how to use my hands
my mom was a pac-man champion a lot of
people don't know that and so whenever i
leave the house
i always regret that i don't have my
console it's a
service from xbox where you play all
your games
like at home or just any game you want
wherever you are
so i'll be like playing like a full-on
driving game i'll be playing gears of
war
if i've got internet i can play like a
real game you know what i mean by like a
real game
like if you play video games you know
what i'm talking about i'm i'm not like
a fan of
like the mobile version of a game i want
to play the real thing and so
this is it by the way people who play
video games in movies and tv shows stop
doing this
that's not real that's not a real thing
video games people are very calm most of
the time when you're really playing a
video game this is what it sounds like
that's real
this has become an essential in my life
i
suffered a vocal cord injury a few
months ago hemorrhagic polyps
and my doctor told me it's because my
voice gets too
dry that's from a lot of flying that's
from not drinking enough water etc and
so i got one of these
a portable humidifier like makes steam
whenever i fly on like up every few
hours i'll just use this
i put this over my face it like
lubricates everything and then it's like
cool
and if you're on a flight where people
can choose their seats no one will sit
next to you
because you look like you're going to
infect everybody on the plane so i just
sit there and everyone i'm like
please join me
join me nobody sits next to you
one final item my timepiece grew up in a
home
where i always loved watches my father
is swiss
so it's almost a prerequisite he would
bring me two things
from switzerland every time he would
come back home to south africa he'd
bring
me a watch and he would bring me the
chocolates
and so i've loved collecting and this is
easily
my most essential piece if i had to keep
one watch in one watch alone
it would be this patek philippe 5650g
the advanced research
one of the most beautiful pieces ever
made in my opinion it's got all of the
work of a patek philippe
a beautiful design but at the same time
it doesn't take itself too seriously you
know you've got this like fun
rubber strap you can wear it whenever
you want you've got the open face i
don't know if you can see that
right you don't see that on any other
particularly this was the first time
where they showed you a few of the
internals of
their timepiece i'm not a big fan of
like diamond watches or anything i think
that's weird because i actually want to
tell the time
but i want to look down and be like
what's the time diamond past two
so this is one of my essentials and it
reminds me of my dad
because that's what we always shared was
a love of time and time keeping
and if you know any swiss people you'll
know that it's not a passion it's what
they have in their bones they're
obsessed with time
a bit crazy if you ask me i just like
the watches
[Music]
well that's my essentials thank you so
much for having me gq and thank you for
watching
if you like any of the stuff i have you
can send an email to my website and i
won't be able to help you
but i will now have your mailing address
which i will use to invite you to all of
my comedy shows
don't email me actually i regret saying
that don't email me about any of these
items please